good afternoon we start with that
breaking news the man running rochdale's
Council housing has been sacked over the
death of a two-year-old boy caused by
molds in his flat awab ishak died from a
respiratory condition caused by the poor
condition of his home in 2020 Rochdale
borrowed housing said the board has
taken the decision to remove Gareth
swarbrick from his post as chief
executive of rbh with immediate effect
we will now work to appoint an external
interim chief executive our original
instincts were for Gareth to stay on and
to see the organization through this
difficult period and to make the
necessary changes but we all recognize
that this is no longer tenable
the coroner noted that rbh had made
changes as a result of the tragic death
of Arab under new leadership rbh will
continue to embed these changes and to
continue to drive further improvements
to our homes and to our Communications
with tenants
and we've been speaking to the leader of
Rochdale Borough Council in the last
hour it's a strange decision because
only what 48 hours ago they were backing
Mr swarbrick To The Hills but I think
it's the right decision but let's
remember as well that we're here today
in memory of poor awabi Shack and to
stand in solidarity with his family to
make sure that something like this never
happens again
well let's go live now to Rochdale and
Skye's freezer mods and and Fraser is
quite the U-turn there from rbh who had
seemed determined to stick on with
Gareth swarbrick as their chief
executive
it certainly seems that way didn't it
for for a while I'm here at a vigil for
our Abhishek and it was just within a
couple of minutes of the vigil starting
that the knees broke that Gareth
swarbrick had been removed from his post
uh less than 48 hours or only 48 hours
or so after rhb had said that they were
sticking with him that they thought that
he was the man to lead them through this
difficult time it now seems as though
they have made a dramatic u-turn on that
statement and decided that his position
was no longer tenable they say that they
want to move forward with other agencies
to try and make improvements but the
council leader saying that that isn't
good enough he wants to see the
properties taken out of rxb control
brought back into Council control he's
going to contact Michael Gove in order
to try and make that happen and he said
that if that is beyond Michael gove's
Powers as the Secretary of State for
housing that he wants to see people
brought in Commissioners brought in from
either the housing Ombudsman or Holmes
England to run the rhb properties until
they can get the confidence of their
tenants back again well I'm joined here
at the moment by psycho Nazis a mental
health professional and also become a
housing campaign because of your
interaction with the people here first
of all what's your reaction to Gauss
walbrick being forced to step down
it's not enough
it's absolutely not enough because
there's a collective making a decision
guys didn't make these decisions on his
own that have led to the death of this
poor boy and and my heart just hurts for
that family and it feels like we're
grieving all over again and I think of
the town it's been quite painful and I
think they all absolutely need to go
need to go we need some somebody
independent to come in and sit with us
as residents of Rochdale and work with
us please we need outside help rhb have
made some action now it took them 53
hours after the inquest to to issue some
form of apology uh for our staff so you
say that they haven't been doing enough
and that they've they've been fighting
against their own responsibilities you
say absolutely at the audacity of them
to think they could have stayed in
position for so long we've been fighting
against them since 2016 and 17 and
they've not been held accountable the
system is not set up for the
working-class people and people who live
in social housing so we really really
need outside intervention before the
mainstream media to exercise off
Rochdale please and in terms of what was
said during that inquest by rhb not
happy with that either absolutely not
it's negligence and they're actually
blaming a whale's family's culture and
religion and that is racism so their
best their decisions by putting the
blame into his culture and religion and
family and its disadvantaged the family
and we really need to be looking at
racism in mental health sorry in social
housing okay well look thanks very much
obviously rhb aren't available to cancer
any claims of racist behavior during the
other interactions with the the coroner
but I can also have a chat now Mark
Slater chair of the Rochdale branch of
the greater Manchester Tenants Union you
must be pleased that rhb have at least
done on something well absolutely but
it's taken too long Gareth walbrich
should have first of all he should have
appeared at the inquest I think that was
only the right and proper thing to do
but it's taken too long to get to this
stage to cut the head off the
organization
tries to deflect the the focus away from
corporate accountability and it does
their do not Escape corporate
accountability this is a board that two
days ago issued a statement a video
statement saying they had full
confidence in Gareth warbrick and two
days later that confidence is suddenly
diminished this is about
self-preservation the amount of money
that was paid to this board in wages is
quite well documented and he's he's in
my my opinion is a reason that Gareth
warbrick has been made the sacrificial
lamb to maintain the um the the board in
the current positions do the council
have the answer the council leader with
her today saying that the 12 000 homes
that RSB run should be brought back
under Council control is that the answer
if it was possible yes it is I don't
think it's I don't think it's an easy
solution but we've been fighting rbh for
a long time for a number of years for
exactly that that solution but I don't
think it's that easy
and it will be now down to Michael gov
to look at all the implications there
are there's not only the logistical
logistical issues to overcome but
there's a matter of funding taking the
homes back back under Council control
means that the council will need some
funding to um to set up the the systems
to administer and to manage those homes
but it would be ideal we've got some
great counselors in this in this town
um councilor Danny Meredith has been
working alongside us as a campaign for
many years it's just unfortunate that
little Al Arab's death has brought it
under the spotlight and and focus
people's minds on social housing not
just in Rochdale but nationally going to
use his seat inside some of the the
properties run by this Association we've
been hearing first-hand accounts of the
the state of some of those properties
what can be done in the immediate term
to to improve the quality of life for
the people who are living in these
substandard conditions well the first
thing that that they can do is make mold
a category one
um a category one
issue that needs dealing with within one
week and that means setting up the
infrastructure to be able to deal with
it to provide ventilation to provide the
removal of of mold and give people a
decent home which is everybody's right
everybody's a right to expect a clean
dry home to live in and these people
particularly the people on on Freehold
you like I have been around Freehold and
being into some of these disgusting
homes our ab's home was described as not
fit for human habitation and it is
disgusting in 2022 that we have families
living in such circumstances
thanks very much for for joining us
today there's been a very good turnout
here to the uh to the video for young
it's been a terrible shock to this
community although many people say that
people living in the housing situation
here have been complaining for years uh
so open family were complaining since
2017 with very little being done by
Rochdale Borough wide housing more needs
to be done more needs to be done very
quickly the council say that they want
to take control it looks as though maybe
sometime before the the situation is
fully resolved in terms of who is going
to try and put the housing situation
here in Rochdale right